tous merci d'être
avec on est en direct c'est
pas merci d'être
là ça
va c'est pas mal il y a un délire j'aime
bien ou franchement il y a un a un bon
délire j me dira que c'est après c'est
c'est demain matin ça va frère mais
qu'est-ce que tu as fait tues pris une
fugie ou
quoi pris c'est pas fini
maintenant
tu as pris une fie c'est pas fini la
musique
maintenant dis-moi tu es pris une fie tu
es pris une fugie par ton voisin ou quoi
je sais que le sommaire ici est
extrêmement réglé justement je vais
parler du voisinage dans un instant
quand vous déménagez les gars faut se
faire respecter dès les premiers jours
dans l'immeubleou bon ah oui ah bah
sinon après tu passes pour une merde ah
mais je te le dis moi je le fais tout le
temps ENF je le faisais avant avant que
j'étais pas connu avec mes parents moi
mes parents quand il m arrivé dans un
immeuble mon frère tout de suite on
s'embrouillit avec deux trois voisins ah
mon qu' était les chefs de l'immeuble
marqu son territoire rappelle un jour un
jour ma mère elle a jeté un pomlemousse
sur la tête d'un voisin
J il avait rien fait mais comme ça parce
que si ils se sont embrouillés se sont
embrouillés mais il faut tout de suite
parce qu'après sinon je connais après ça
dire ouais ça met la musique tout ça toi
tu t'es pris une fugie par le voisin du
deuxè
c'est c'est quoi la c'est quoi la pox
est-ce que vous avez 30 secondes pour
que je dise enfin ce que j'ai sur le
cœur ou là ou là oh oh tu vas nous faire
une tirim ou
quoi vous me dites alors bah vas-y vas-y
vous avez toutes les qualités vous êtes
génial mais en matière capillaire vous
êtes un
[Applaudissements]
pitrey cette coiffure cette coiffure
elle vient directement de Londres tout
le monde est coiffé comme ça et j'ai une
coiffeuseour ah oui mais j'ai une
coiffeuse qui revient de Londres et qui
a passé 1 heure ça fait genreas
exactement toi ça fait ça fait
sprite déconner ça fait ça fait ma
coiffeuse c'est Kelly non mais
arrête arrêtez de vous de sa
gueule arrêtez arrêtez de vous de
sa gueule j'ai mis une heure à le
coiffer c'est parce que vous venez
revenez de Londres et vous l'avez
coiffer comme ça dit je lui ai dit que
j'avais pensé à lui tout le weekend j'ai
vu des dandis londoniens magnifiques et
je me suis dit Gill il leur ressemble
tellement qu'il faut mais c'est vrai bah
vous auriez mieux fait d'aller avec elle
et rester là-bas
franchement
pas mal en mode magnifique c'est
catastrophique je te dis déjà qui pécha
des meufs entre toi et moi il sort d'un
machine à donc fais ce que tu fais ce
que fais comme moi fais la même pcou
voilà c'est tout voilà non mais c'est il
y a pas que les cheveux chur anglais les
stars anglaises elles sont comme ça elle
a vu des TOC àond regarde là elle est
revenue elle a mis un papier aluminium
frère
[Applaudissements]
elle a fait le marathon de londr ou quoi
vous avez fait le marathon non c'est pas
mal suime arrte magif elle elle elle a
le droit de ver tout le monde elle on a
Paso de la valer tout le temps tu sais
elle est non mais c'est dingue ça et
redescendez hein je peux ber tout le
monde aujourd'hui vous allez prendre
dans la gueule tu vas voir comme ça ça
va la CAL tu es très bien
coiffé Gilles tu es très bien coiffé tu
es magnifique par contre toi qu'est tu
es malade ou quoi tu as une grippe mais
quoi c'est quoi ce pull frère j'aime
bien je trouve que c'est non mais c'est
qu'on passe à la télé il y a des gens
qui nous regardent il est hyper joli
c'est une petite marinière sauf que
plutôt que de faire bleu marine et blanc
j'ai fait on est passé sur moi je cro ah
on est passé sur tu vas jouer avec des
chiffres et des lettres mon frère il est
en
veloursour c'est pas toi mais c'est pas
toi arrête VO plus ça va
vachement
[Musique]
bien c'est pas mal mais toi c'est
dégueulasseect alors c'est quoi moi dis-
avec toi comme
ça tu vois c'est plus ça je t'aurais
passé ça tu m'aurais passé ça je pense
qu'on devra on devrait
switch pas ça velour un Velon Liss
vour tu es bon dans les mais moins bien
dans les
pass un
weekend mais
ça s'il vous plaît on est sorti ensemble
la semaine il y a 3 semaines le connais
je sais comment il se comporte il est
magnifique merci mon et tu as quoi sous
ta vesteah il a rien j'ai mis un t-shirt
noir
so Cu le pantalonou pantalon alors
pantalon en cuir tu transpires beaucoup
frère de l'entrefesse ouais ouais non
mais c'est vrai oui excusez-moi dans un
pantalon il y a quoi pas tard à nous
faire une JeanMichel mer
s ça va monel oui je sais pas tuas tuas
ah pas du tout moi tout va bien je te
sens moi non non non c'est que non tu es
là le lundi maintenant ben oui ça me
fait plaisir d'ailleurs bah c'est parce
que je t'appelle ben oui ais c'est très
touchant tu sais pourquoi tu es là lundi
ça pas duré parce qu'on parle souvent de
Jade et Joy le lundi je sais et on dit
qui pe il peut parler frère par contre
toi frère euh cadeau va faire un nuuv
progr programme sage il pas maquillé je
me suis je me suis retourné frère je me
suis retourné je croyais frère à mon
avis tu décèdes dans 20 minutes merci
merci à mon avis 19h18 c'est capoute
belle prévision mais frérot je te je
t'adore rien ne va aujourd'hui
alors qui t'a maquill aussi non tu vois
pas qu'elle veut du mal Kelly jamais non
Kelly vous êtes très belle ce soir bravo
parce faut faire com parce qu' elle est
vénère donc
connais
elle est contente voilà mais
c'est ça vous avez vu l'ego des gens il
y a que moi qui n''est pas d'ego
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici rigol c'est
insortable mais moi j'en ai rien à taper
mais moi ça glisse sur moi ça glisse ça
glisse sur moi ça glisse tu voyez pas
vous et mais oh ça me dégoûte ces gens
de
téloges je déteste ça non mais c'est
vrai vous êtes toujours en train tu vois
le Montiel là le truc quoi qu'est-ce
qu'il a le Montiel il a rien fait il a
rien dit par contre tu vas
prendre tu fais gaffe he non ça va mon
chéri oui j'ai fait j'ai fait mais non
alors je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
parce que j'ai tourné animaux une
émission que vous adorez je le sais avec
avec Christine Kelly voilà mais oui et
et cathertherina Murino que vous aviez
apprécié ah elle est sympa voilà
qu'est-ce que tu en a à ben je
sais bien jeis pub si vous voulez parce
que vous au moins il y a 2 million moi
j'ai
400000 400000 sur la chaîne anim vous
emmerde 400000 cumulé sur
200 sur
20sououi je sais que je suis fou mais
j'adore tuas fait un doigt
là je sais pas faire les doigts moi
c'est lui qui m'a
appris vas-y va faire
des vas-y va faire des à ton pantalon là
faire des à ton pantalonire vas-y va
faire des à ton
pantalon va faire desol à ton pantalon
là ça va toi frérot é gooute super c'est
à quelle heure la chass à la
perdrille service
militaire dis-moi il y a de la perdie un
peu là dans le quartierad excuse-moi ton
pantalon il s'est coincé dans la machine
à coudre ou
quoi la nov alors quand on do compris ça
règle d'or quand on doit expliquer une
Nova c'est qu'elle est pas bonne c'est
la règle d'or ça c'est violent moi
j'aurais mal pris je l'aurais dégagé
mais frère tu as une tenue à jouer les
proviseurs sur dans une série qu notire
vas-y mais
frère ah mais oui ah oui les Pons les
pepons elles sont folles dir des de
contrôleur de c'est vrai c'estur de bus
tu peux me
ramener alors je reconnais que c'est
vrai c'est
vra retourne dans ta
cabine une bonne
ambianceanchement trs bonne
amb la bienveillance
c'est me c'est ça qu'on Kiffe kiffe on
est on est tous potes en fait c'est vrai
on s'adore ça exactement par contre pas
trop
toi un peu ENIT toi c'est magnifique toi
vous aimez bien ouis alors comment ne
pas aimer ou ça s deain notreuch alors
vous savez qu'il y a une très bonne
ambiance dans les coulisses et on était
dans la loge de Kathy notre notre
habilleuse et Kelly est arrivé vraiment
spectaculaire quand elle est arrivée
debout et on a fait une photo tous de
groupe comme ça il y avait une très très
bonne ambiance sur un cané vous me la
passerez vous me la passerez parce que
c'est important non pas ça c'est
important que je vois ceux qui me
manqueront l'année prochaine ceux qui
seront pas là non mais ça ça vous va
hyper bien par contre le bowling c'est à
quelle heure tout le monde y
passe non il a pas fait la photo avec
vous lui non il arrive derni moment par
c'est c'est mon ami il se mélange pas
avec
vous arrive vraiment au dernier
moment il rentre juste avant vous sur le
PL m pour
lui franchement là je t'ai revu parce
que je suis venu
là je et ben merci bah je me suis trompé
sur toi c'est plus moderne franchement
c'est non franchement c'est pas mal du
tout merci c'est c'est non vraiment je
te jure en fait il faut te voir il faut
en fait il faut que te regarder que
comass vite fait il faut te regarder en
billet com faut te regarder que comass
en fait tu voux ou pas faut te regarder
vite F il faut pas tu vois faut pas
rester sur si on reste tu vois on peut
faire on fait com ah ouais pas mal tu
vois et en fait après on voit que tu es
dégueulasse allez on va se retrouver
dans un
instant
on